LIKE BERNIE ARE THE BEST.
>> Bret: PETER DOOCY,
THANK YOU.
AN UNFILTERED ANALYSIS OF THE
2020 PRESIDENTIAL RACE AND MANY
MORE TOPICS, WE TURN NOW TO A
SYNDICATED RADIO TALK SHOW HOST,
RUSH LIMBAUGH.
HE JOINS US LIVE FROM HIS
STUDIO.
GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO
"SPECIAL REPORT."
>> IT IS GREAT TO BE HERE, THIS
IS A MILESTONE FOR ME.
MY FIRST EVER APPEARANCE ON YOUR
PROGRAM AND I AM HONORED TO BE
HERE.
>> Bret: IT HAS BEEN A COUPLE
DAYS SINCE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
WROTE THAT FOUR-PAGE LETTER
DESCRIBING HIS CONCLUSIONS FROM
THE MUELLER REPORT.
WHAT IS YOUR ASSESSMENT OF THE
FALLOUT SINCE THAT TIME?
>> I THINK HE THOUGHT AS A
DISTRACTION.
WE HAVE TO KEEP TRACK OF EXACTLY
WHAT THIS BLOWS.
THERE WAS ZERO COLLUSION.
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION AND THERE
WAS NEVER ANY EVIDENCE OF ANY
COLLUSION BETWEEN TRUMP OR HIS
CAMPAIGN AND RUSSIA.
ZILCH, ZERO, NADA.
TO BEGIN INVESTIGATION BASED ON
A PHONY DOSSIER THAT WAS CREATED
AND WRITTEN BY ASSOCIATES OF
HILLARY CLINTON.
HE WAS OPPOSITION RESEARCH AND
THIS IS OUTRAGEOUS WHAT HAS
HAPPENED HERE.
THERE NEEDS TO BE AN
INVESTIGATION INTO THIS AND
THERE NEEDS TO BE ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR EVERYBODY WHO PARTICIPATED
IN THIS, FROM PEOPLE HIGH UP IN
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION AND ALL
THE WAY DOWN AND INCLUDING MOST
OF THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
IT HAS BEEN TWO YEARS THAT WE
HAVE BEEN DISTRACTED --
THIS COUNTRY HAS BEEN GOING
THROUGH HELL.
THEY WERE TOLD THEIR PRESIDENT
WAS A TRAITOR!
THEY WERE SURE HE STOLE THE
ELECTION AND NONE OF IT HAPPENED
IN THE SPECIAL COUNSEL HAS KNOWN
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION SINCE
BEFORE THE INVESTIGATION BEGAN.
THERE HAS NEVER BEEN ANY
EVIDENCE OF IT.
I DON'T CARE WHAT HE SAYS AND I
DON'T CARE WHAT JAMES COMEY SAYS
WERE ANY OF THE REST OF THEM.
THIS WILL THINK IS A
MANUFACTURED COUP BECAUSE THESE
PEOPLE COULD NOT ACCEPT THE
RESULTS OF THE 2016 ELECTION AND
THEIR CONTINUING!
THEY ARE CONTINUING TO TRY.
YOU LOOK AT SCHIFF, THEIR
CONDUCT ILLUSTRATES THAT THIS IS
AN ONGOING POLITICAL PROJECT TO
GET RID OF DONALD TRUMP.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
FINDING OUT IF A FOREIGN POWER
HAS ANYTHING TO DO WITH OUR
ELECTIONS BECAUSE A FOREIGN
POWER TO TODD.
>> Bret: HE MENTIONED
CONGRESSMAN SCHIFF, THEY SAID
THEY WANT TO SEE ALL 300 PLUS
PAGES OF THE MUELLER REPORT AND
THEY ARE SAYING THAT THERE COULD
BE MORE IN THERE.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> I THINK HE ACTS ON RUSH'S
BEHALF AND HE PUTS RUSSIA'S
INTERESTS I HAD TO OPT OF
AMERICANS INTERESTS.
>> THERE IS AMPLE EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION IN PLAIN SIGHT AND
THAT IS TRUE.
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE OF EVIDENCE
OF COLLUSION AND PROOF BEYOND
REASONABLE DOUBT OF A CRIME.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> THERE IS NO EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION!
THE MAN IS LYING THROUGH HIS
TEETH AND THIS IS WHAT I MEAN
THAT HE IS TRYING TO KEEP THIS
ALIVE.
I HEARD TODAY IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," GUESS WHAT
IT IS ACTUALLY 300 PAGES AND
BILL BARR SUMMARIZED IT IN FOUR?
ARE THEY SERIOUS?
THEY REALLY --
NANCY PELOSI WANTS US TO BELIEVE
THAT BILL BARR IS LYING ABOUT
WHAT IS IN THIS REPORT AND THAT
THERE IS EVIDENCE IN THIS
REPORT!
IF THAT IS TRUE THEN WHAT MUST
THEY THINK OF BILL BARR?
WHERE IS MUELLER?
HE IS LYING ABOUT THIS AND I
FOUND COLLUSION!
I THOUGHT OBSTRUCTION!
IT IS IN MY REPORT.
THE 19 PRO-HILLARY INVESTIGATORS
ON THE STAFF.
IT IS JUST INTO DOING.
THEY ARE LYING TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY CAN'T GIVE
IT UP.
IT IS OUTRAGEOUS AND SOME OF
THESE PEOPLE NEED TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
I HOPE THE PRESIDENT CALLS A
SPECIAL COUNSEL TO LOOK INTO
THIS BECAUSE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
DESERVE TO KNOW HOW THEY'VE BEEN
MANIPULATED, HOW THEY HAVE BEEN
USED.
THEY DESERVE TO KNOW WITH THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY THE AMERICAN
LEFT DISSENTING FROM THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION ATTEMPTED TO PULL
OFF HERE.
IT BETTER NEVER HAPPEN AGAIN.
THIS IS PROBABLY THE BIGGEST
POLITICAL SCANDAL CERTAINLY OF
OUR LIFETIME MAY BE EVEN LONGER.
>> Bret: THE PRESIDENT CALLED
IN WITH SEAN HANNITY AND TALKED
ABOUT THE FISA DOCUMENTS THAT
STARTED THIS INVESTIGATION AND
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID.
>> I HAVE PLANS TO DECLASSIFY
AND RELEASE, I HAVE PLANS TO
ABSOLUTELY RELEASE.
I HAVE SOME VERY TALENTED PEOPLE
WORKING FOR ME, LAWYERS.
I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE BETTER TO
HOLD IT TO THE END.
I DID THE RIGHT THING BY NOT
DOING IT SO FAR.
>> Bret: TO THANK --
YOU ARE CALLING FOR A SPECIAL
COUNSEL?
IS THERE A SPECIAL COUNSEL
OVERLOAD WITH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE?
>> WHAT WAS THAT?
>> Bret: OVERLOAD, OUR
PEOPLE --
>> THERE IS THAT POSSIBILITY.
HOW ELSE WOULD WE GET --
I UNDERSTAND, TWO YEARS AND CAN
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE PUT UP WITH
THIS?
I ASKED MYSELF THE SAME
QUESTION.
THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT.
IF YOU WOULD DECLASSIFY
EVERYTHING TO DO WITH PFIZER AND
EVERYTHING TO DO WITH HIS
INVESTIGATION AND THEN
ANNOUNCING HE IS CLOSING THE
BORDER AND SHUTTING DOWN
IMMIGRATION AND WE CAN GET A
HANDLE ON IT.
AND THEN PARDON EVERYBODY THAT
HAS BEEN ABUSED BY THIS
UNNECESSARY INVESTIGATION.
HE MENTIONED PFIZER, FOR CRYING
OUT LOUD WHERE THE JUDGES ON
THIS?
A PHONY OPPOSITION RESEARCH
DOCUMENT CALLED A DOSSIER WAS
USED FOUR TIMES, THERE'S NOT A
SHRED OF EVIDENCE AND NET.
NONE OF IT HAS BEEN COOPERATED
AND THEY USED IT TO GET WARREN
TO SPY ON THE OPPOSING
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN FOUR
DIFFERENT TIMES!
THERE HAS NEVER BEEN AT THE
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION!
I KEEP REPEATING THIS BECAUSE --
I'M ADAMANT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS HAPPENING.
THIS IS A HUGE HOAX THAT HAS
BEEN PERPETRATED THAT MAKES
EVERY OTHER HOAX THAT OUR
LIFETIME PALE IN COMPARISON.
NOT A SHRED OF EVIDENCE, ALL
FOUR WARRANTS WERE BASED ON
ABSOLUTELY DEAF DUMB MIKE DUNN
LIKE ABSOLUTE LIES PUT TOGETHER
BY HILLARY CLINTON'S CAMPAIGN.
IT IS OUTRAGEOUS TO ME.
>> Bret: EVEN SEAN HANNITY,
LAURA INGRAHAM AND MARK LEVANT,
A SMALL GROUP BELIEVE THAT FROM
DAY ONE.
WE CAN TAKE YOU BACK TWO YEARS
AGO YOU WERE SAYING ROUGHLY THE
SAME THING AND ONE OF THE
REASONS WE WANTED TO TALK TO
YOU.
WHEN YOU GO AROUND THE COUNTRY
THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE WHO
SUPPORT THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
ACTIONS AND WHAT HIS
ADMINISTRATION IS DOING.
THEY DON'T LIKE THE WAY HE
TREATS OR TALKS OR ATTACKS HIS
OPPONENTS.
WHAT YOU SAY TO THOSE PEOPLE?
>> I SAY HE SHOULD CONTINUE
TWEETING AND LOOK AT THE FORCES
THAT ARE ALIGNED AGAINST THEM.
HE HAS WHAT EVERYBODY THINKS IS
A MEDIA.
WE DON'T HAVE A MEDIA IN THIS
COUNTRY, THERE ISN'T A GROUP OF
PEOPLE REPORTING THE NEWS AND
TELLING US WHAT HAPPENED THAT WE
DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT.
WE HAVE DEMOCRATIC ACTIVISTS AND
LEFT-WING HACKS THAT ARE
DISGUISED AS JOURNALISTS THAT
ARE HELPING PROPEL THE EFFORT TO
GET RID OF DONALD TRUMP.
THE ONLY PUSHBACK, THE ONLY
OPPORTUNITY TO GET HIS SIDE OF
HIS VIA HIS TWEETS.
I HOPE --
PLUS THERE IS MONEY.
I HOPE HE KEEPS IT UP.
I'M A TRUMP SUPPORTER UNABASHED
AND I LOVE THEM.
IT DOES NOT BOTHER ME IN ANY WAY